um
let's talk about the other his
counterpart at amazon at bezos
so this is the tampa facility of amazon
um there's a lot of things that that go
on with amazon that
look regardless then i mean this
sincerely regardless of what side of
politics you land on
jeff bezos is a slave
is is a slave running piece of [ __ ] the
things that he does is
yeah is this the wage ekg that i've been
mentioning yeah i've been talking about
that i've been talking about the wagey
kg for a while it's not called the wage
cage it's actually called
um amazon it's called an it's called a
wagey cage it's what it's always been
called
since they tried to propose this 10
years ago and everybody was pissed
they actually made the wage cage
amazon which is the uh off brand amazon
so uh this is uh what what they do like
you know so their facilities
these things are actually all true so
their facilities um
first off they're they they underpay
them so much that they still qualify for
welfare
that's a fact um and what they did was
once they did the you know
certain states that you have to pay
fifteen dollars an hour they did that
but they made them part-time so they
wouldn't have to give the medical
benefits because
only full-timers come back but on top of
that look working in their factory is
hard um i actually talked to somebody
that works at the one down the road
and um which this part makes sense out
you know um
they metal detector you and they do like
an x-ray thing when you walk in and when
you walk out to make sure you're not
stealing stuff which that's fine
however you need to take a piss break
you most of these people are pissing in
jugs
and jars piss jugs i mean what is too
good for piss jugs
so amazon uh decided hey you know when
you get tired here's what we're gonna do
with amazon i wanted to provide a place
that's quiet
that people could go and focus on their
mental and
emotional well-being
the zen booth is an interactive kiosk
where you can navigate through
a library of mental health and mindful
practices
to recharge that internal battery on
your time
yeah of course it's on your time and you
get to go in this little booth
where you get uh you get recharged they
you're recharged yes yes right this this
is one of
one of those jackoff booths in japan
right
no no no no no this is nothing like that
um what you do is
you go in this booth and still wear a
mask in there for some reason though
you're alone
and you you they play mental health
videos while you realize wow this
company is not paying me anything
this is brutal and there's a high risk
of death this is so
[ __ ] brutal so uh it's up to
trolita by hey trollita she's calling it
a cuck closet
[ __ ] closet wage cage
i would take the biggest [ __ ] in that
thing yeah i would either
[ __ ] in it or smoke weed and it would be
one of them you open in a plume of smoke
and then you do this move royce knows
this move you make eye contact
that was somebody else did that earlier
i don't know and you keep walking
by the way you can't deal when the
smoke's pouring out
the smell you can blame but i've
straight up walked out of a room where
there was smoke coming out and i've been
like
yeah somebody must have been smoking in
here earlier that's disgusting
people in the chat are equating this to
the suicide booths from futurama
that's right i would have more respect
for amazon if they offered suicide
booths
because at least you get something out
of it at least you don't have to go to
that [ __ ]
shitty job anymore we're calling it the
amazon permanent
break room
[Laughter]
up dude imagine because you know the
company spends money on these things and
it's like
how about spending that money on i don't
know treating our employees better
like i'm not some shitty like this is
one of the things that like
besides republican democrat that like
they love getting us fighting over
yeah is and it's it is one of the
one of the ways they kind of keep us is
the the communism versus the free market
like
everyone thinks the other side is a
hundred percent wrong
right like that's why i love when they
bash socialism and you're like
yes i don't want to live in a place that
is 100
socialist right but 100 capitalism is
also bad right it should be it should be
like a nice
recipe right it should be like 80 20.
you know what i mean 80 20 i think is a
good you should have some
social program like otherwise you are
living in a dystopian hellhole if you
don't have some programs to help people
but like they keep the socialism versus
free market guys always strangling each
other but it's like
if we could get together and all agree
that this
is evil then i think we rather than just
fight over communism
capitalism failed man communism killed
more people man
all right hey everyone stop can we start
by saying
this is awful right oh no you mentioned
at the first hour this is another
robocop commercial yes
it's it's these these things that are
real now were robocop commercials
you know it's funny because it's funny
you say that go in there and i would re
we'll rewire the [ __ ] computer so
that it was just playing
infowars clips and then leave and then
go i don't know who was using it last
you know it's uh it's funny i uh
i was watching um you you heard about
the whole blackrock thing right the
investment firm that's been buying up
homes
so this blackrock is an investment firm
that has been just oh yeah they've been
gobbling up
gobbling up homes and what's happening
is if you're a new home buyer
the prices are skyrocketing because
they're just buying it for investments
which is going to cause another bubble
and it's going to crash
whatever and even some republicans have
been saying like look
this is [ __ ] up because like we're
hurting actual first-time homebuyers of
these companies
you know who defended it ben shapiro you
saw it right
ben shapiro did an entire like 15
minutes segment folks if you're poor and
disgusting
then why are you even alive look these
companies are doing what they have to do
and that way you can't afford a house or
have children which is fine
because capitalism rules look don't get
me wrong i like capitalism but
capitalism
shouldn't capitalism be a tool that we
use not a [ __ ] lifestyle
well it's also the fact that it's crony
capitalism we don't like the
blackrock gets um you know blackrock
barely pays taxes it's another one of
these companies that doesn't
it has lobbyists it has you know dudes
on the inside
that's the [ __ ] that kills it it's not
capitalism necessarily that's bad
but if you um try to get a leg up you're
gonna get stomped on i mean look what
happened with wall street bets
look what happened with the stock market
those people would have rather crashed
the stock market into the ground
to spite you rather than letting people
get a leg up that's just how they are
so it's it's not necessarily
just like to to dismiss the black water
the the black water black rock thing as
just
same thing at this point but to dismiss
it is capitalism
this is capitalism man it's like no but
we have created a class of like
ultra corporation like we are creating a
[ __ ]
cyberpunky future like a shadowrun
future where
it's gonna be chinese and japanese mega
corpse
uh named all our stadiums and then it's
that's the end of it
like it's just that's scary there should
be capitalism should be like
go watch like deadwood right or go watch
like stuff about like when america was
first founded that was capitalism
because it was like
okay i'm gonna go to this town that this
guy
bought all the land and it's his town
and i'm gonna go buy a license from him
for a lot and now i own this lot of land
in
on main street and then i'm going to
build my hardware store there
and i own this lot of lane like that
used to be and then if somebody else
wanted to open up a better hardware
store
and [ __ ] you then that would open up
over there but if there's no longer a
high i'm going to go open up a [ __ ]
where what town that has a [ __ ]
lowe's and a home depot
is your dumb [ __ ] ass gonna go open up a
[ __ ] hardware store it's not gonna
happen
well that's the thing you know and it's
not just that blackrock is buying up
these homes they're buying up at a 30
they're putting a 30
percent increase cap from what the
market value is cash they're putting it
down
cash and they're buying it so what's
happening is is that people that do work
hard people that want to buy a home now
they have to rent for the rest of their
lives you know you have to just use your
rent that's it guess what you rent for
the rest of your lives and that's it
but ben shapiro thinks it's fine folks
okay capitalism is awesome what do you
want these investment companies to do
you want them not to buy up stuff and
and and falsely inflate the market that
way when it crashes later what are you
gonna do it doesn't matter i'm still
making money folks
yeah you gotta start thinking creatively
like i wanna i wanna own
i don't wanna stay renting forever but
i'm never gonna be in a bracket where i
can just outright buy
like so i the way i've been looking at
it is
i've been looking in like you know where
like lake wales is at i love lake wales
and there's a lot of attractive land
right now for sale there in
neighborhoods that aren't even developed
yet but they're just selling off the
tracks of land
i'm trying to find a piece of land first
because you can get that for like
20 grand and you can get that without a
quote-unquote mortgage because they'll
you know what i mean that's that's an
amount of money you can just finance
without all the [ __ ] mortgage [ __ ]
and then own a piece of land and
honestly dude i don't care for a couple
years i gotta slap a double wide on that
[ __ ]
that's still a two-bedroom two-bath and
it's mine at least i ain't paying nobody
anything you know
and then eventually price out and figure
out how to build a house
that's the future of trying to be a
homeowner it's not gonna be
you're gonna have to start doing this
[ __ ] in sections like okay i'll find a
plot of land
that's in a place that's kind of up and
coming i'll just buy it i'll pay that
off first then i own the land
then get it perk tested get the
utilities ran to it and then just go
look
i'm throwing a double wide on that [ __ ]
for a couple years
living there it's fine and then
eventually when you have the money go
now you can start building out a house
while living in the double wide it's the
only way you can do it anymore
uh to know i have a video of merch from
the future
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's good to have land i love that clip
by the way joe sanders says you can hand
dig your basement yeah we live in
florida we don't have a thing called
basically
imagine ticky to the
uh amazon and then i just created i
create a sinkhole that destroys everyone
else's plots and then they're like now
you owe me
eight hundred thousand dollars no but um
my
my goal and i've been looking into this
for real is
i looked into florida state laws
regarding um
outdoor shooting and if i find the right
location
i only need maybe two acres and i'm
allowed to legally
shoot on my land which is pretty dope
that's what i want
i don't care if i slap a double wide on
two acres as long as i can legally have
an
outdoor range at my house [ __ ] tight
there's the new amazon thing they're
releasing this is the box to use your
imagination